hello I'm Conan O'Brien and like
millions of Americans I've hosted a
late-night TV show for the past 25 years
that's over 4,000 hours of classic
entertainment most of it unseen since it
first aired until now with the release
of my remotes which have been digitally
remastered on Team Coco comm you might
be wondering how we turned all these old
shows into a digital format well it's
simple take one of my favorite emotes
when I played old timey baseball first
we take this shitty tape my brother Neal
recorded off his TV and convert it to
DVD incredible then the DVD is converted
into a 3d IMAX film which we then screen
for a hip-hop dance squad who transform
it into a bomb-ass routine an artist and
watches the dance and reinterprets that
into a surrealist oil painting which is
viewed by a cat wearing a motion capture
suit while a computer converts its
movements into a digital wireframe the
digital wireframe is transformed into
computer animation that one's most
grueling yawn - - a hanna-barbera
cartoon it was both cooling on my
mustache then anime you that you were to
go to there and claymation it was most
cooling on my mustache
please Kuby again a DVD of which is
converted back into VHS and finally that
tape is run through an algorithm that
converts claymation to live-action and
uploads it to the Internet and that was
our final tape mission accomplished just
found more tapes
please kill me